[Music]
lamar jackson with that awesome spin
move one of the great plays of the 2019
season i could watch it over and over
and over again
it inspired today's draft the all-time
offensive plays because we decided you
know what there's defensive plays too
we'll do that tomorrow today it's the
all-time offensive plays that make you
go oh when you see them and we all
shouted that out in the viewing room at
nbc when it happened last year between
the ravens and the bengals okay so
that's today's draft trivia question is
in the possession of christopher david
sims he will ask it to me if i get it
right i get the first pick
well i know that big cat likes to say
that you look like uh the paulie walnuts
from the sopranos right
say that i don't look like paulie
walnuts where's that guy that's what he
says he does he does he does
he he said he's eventually going to with
his gray hair that he that he dies he
thinks
he thinks if you if you admit that you
dye your hair it makes it okay go ahead
i don't know there's some that are
arguing that you kind of look like it
too but either way in honor of did i dye
my hair
you've seen me in person this is great
lighting there's a lot of grey hair
there is a lot of gray it looks good all
right in in lieu of that okay
what's polly walnut's real last name in
the show the sopranos what's his real
last name eyes eyes up there no no
typing
i'm not i'm not typing uh what's his
name what's his last name uh i have no
idea i have no idea
you got noah i have no idea all right
i'm not sure
yeah i would never even come close that
just sounds like you made it up on the
spot i uh
just sometimes i don't know for sure
either i'm not sure all right all right
go ahead you got the first pick
man
there's so many to pick from do you not
find this draft hard i really do i mean
i have like 20 options written down
right now well and let's let's be clear
let's be clear to everyone this isn't
the best plays of all time this is the
the plays that elicit that visceral in
the moment when you see it you you can't
contain yourself that's what this is
right and i tried to pick guys that
do this consistently right in lieu of
like lamar jackson it wasn't like one
one one hit run uh wonder would that
play we just saw against the bengals
we're talking about guys that this kind
of like
describes them in their career at least
this is what i went with you don't have
to do that i know you don't you're not a
smart that's fine listen
one of us can execute the draft as it
was designed and one of us can just come
up with some completely different
standard that he's pulling out of thin
air or somewhere else that's fine that's
your that's your prerogative if you want
to make picks based on something other
than what the draft is that's your
prerogative go ahead well i'm gonna make
a pick on what the draft is and then
make a pick to also just shove it up
your butt and my first one's gonna be
michael vick running down the left
sideline against the minnesota vikings
splitting defenders touchdown falcons
and michael vic sia minnesota you're
going home a loser and mike mike florio
may be crying but to me like that one
that play and i don't know if we're
gonna have the highlight of it but if
you can remember in your brand and i'm
sure you can i remember
over time dropping back to pass against
the minnesota vikings scrambles to his
left turns it up field and then
turns on the afterburners to an extent
in which we had never seen a quarterback
ever run like that i mean that was like
whoa are we watching deion sanders or is
this a quarterback i mean that's what
kind of speed he showed to me that'll be
a play i never forget in my life because
i know i had never seen a quarterback do
that and i went oh my gosh i've never
seen anything like this in in the
history of the nfl a guy that can make
these kind of plays not only with a big
arm but unbelievable running ability uh
so that was one of those that will
always ring true to me as far as a play
that goes oh and here it is oh baby
[Music]
here's the thing this and i'm not taking
anything away from the mike vic
afterburner what makes the play is the
keystone cops routine when the two
vikings crash into each other
yeah it did it made it good thank you
vikings for delivering on that aspect of
the play
but that was and you know what that was
the that was an oh moment and it also
felt like a mike vic welcome to the nfl
moment like right not the typical
welcome to the nfl like he was a big hit
but just like that that was his coming
out party that was when people realized
this guy's gonna be every bit as good at
this level as he was at virginia tech
see that wasn't that bad that was on
theme wasn't that on theme though i mean
okay but your desire
to stick it to me
you're i i cannot believe you did this i
cannot believe it there is one and only
one
all-time
oh jump out of your seat moments in the
national football league especially in
the last 10 years and it was the catch
made by your guy odo beckham jr in his
rookie year on sunday night football
when somehow some way that ball is
coming in from 50 yards on the fly from
eli manning and somehow he falls
backward
grabs the ball out of the air with one
hand secures the catch
and it's one of those things that you
had to watch a hundred times just to
process what you had seen there's been
nothing like it this is one of the
greatest place it's unbelievable chris i
see it now and it makes me want to jump
up how did it go did you blow this did
you think i wasn't going to take it
i don't know look at that i got it i got
20 different plays written down and i
pick odell beckham jr i feel like in
every other draft we have so i tried to
change because you do all right you
think that because you do
i know so i let you have it this time i
knew that was gonna get picked here at
some point but
no i mean really
that's the greatest catch i've ever seen
by a guy you know by any receiver you
know it's it's it's like the david tyree
catch but david tyree was like a one-hit
wonder i mean i can't remember one other
reception he had in his career
odell we knew had great hands at that
point but you're right that took it to
another stratosphere you're just like
whoa this guy's different than even i
expected
david tyree it felt like the hand of god
was in play there that it was such a
rare unusual event if we're talking
about athleticism if we're talking about
something that when you see it you
assume it will be duplicated that it
will be replicated that it will be not
that we've seen another one like it
because you need the right circumstances
but it showed us what this guy's capable
of and that to me it's i that that's i
mean when you're talking about it
for 15 minutes after it happened and
we're talking about it for five minutes
right now
uh it's it just shows you what a play it
was all right you're up
all right um
i think here i'm gonna go
i'm gonna go to
barry sanders all right you remember
barry sanders 1991 divisional playoff
game they're playing the dallas cowboys
you know he had so many marquee runs but
here it is i mean this is when i think
of barry sanders this is the play i
always think of i mean running into a
pile of people and then guys on the
dallas cowboys being like he's down
right and then he's running for a
touchdown and they're like what what
they're looking different ways like
which way did he go which way did he go
to me that just like signifies one of
the greatest players we've ever had in
the sport and it's the play i always
think of when i think of him and a play
that made me go oh because it wasn't one
of the biggest moments of his career as
far as game wise they weren't in the
playoffs a lot through barry sanders
career as we know that was a dallas
cowboys team that everybody thought was
ooh they could maybe go into detroit and
beat the lions and of course we know
they were you know building a dynasty
there at that time with the cowboys and
and start start that the next year but
that run right there just epitomizes
what barry sanders is all about the
greatest in space runner in the history
of the in the nfl and the greatest
running back i've ever seen in my
lifetime
i i considered barry sanders but i
couldn't pick a play i remember a play
against the bears it was a week one game
where it was bottled up behind the line
and then all of a sudden he was shot out
of a cannon right there was so many
plays like that for barry sanders all
right next one for me and usually when
we talk vikings cowboys old school
highlights on this show
old school highlight that comes up
no no i'm not picking that one the one
you're picking is from
i bet the one in particular thanksgiving
day 1998.
he had three catches for 150 plus yards
and three touchdowns but it was the last
one that was the one
that that was uncanny that was because
it's one thing i look it's great when
you see the ball arc through the air and
the guy makes a big catch
impressive when a guy takes a little
flat pass and just finds a gear that
you've never seen before and guys who
think they have an angle he does a
little shoulder dip full speed right
there and and it freezes the guy and
it's just like see you later it is man
among
boys that to me that that that was
that's a moment that's a moment that
resonates 22 years later
uh it is mike it was you know it might
have been my next pick so i mean i'm
with you that to me i can still remember
sitting on the couch
watching that you know at my home in
jersey and and just going like man i
can't wait to watch the cowboys versus
randy moss and seeing him do some of
those things that day especially that
play you're right because we had never
seen a receiver that long and tall
just open up and blow everybody away on
the field in a race i mean he was like
usain bolt running down the sideline
there
so i'm with you that was an all-time
great all right i'm going to go to dion
sanders here i mean i'm going back to
back sanders dion sanders 1989 his first
regular season game as a player for the
atlanta falcons they're playing the rams
and this is his first punt return
touchdown as an nfl football player and
now as a young kid you know deon sanders
was on my radar just because i was like
who is this loud you know gold chains
you know can can talk a lot it's always
expectable he's wearing number two in
florida state he's so cool i kind of
loved him early on right away from day
one and then he went there and did that
where i don't know if anybody remembers
this play but i'll try my best to
explain it gets a punt kind of fumbles
it drops on the ground picks it up makes
a few people miss reverses field and
then has like a 60-something yard punt
return down the right sideline to be
like
oh whoa dion sanders is real and of
course that continued to be a theme for
the rest of his career but you know to
me deion sanders has a few of those
plays in his career where
he's still i think the fastest guy i've
ever seen on a field in the history of
the nfl it's either him a tyree kill it
was pretty special
all right time for my pick round three
the all-time moment that makes you go oh
and it was this one larry fitzgerald
breaks into clear and there are three
guys and they have no chance he he
continues to run away from them and that
was the moment where i thought boy the
cardinals are going to win the super
bowl but to me look
the athleticism here is just in the
explosion and the disappearance
and and the shock of the moment i think
it's a combination of all those things
chris i will never forget how it felt to
be in the stadium that day when that
happened
yeah that was uh that was a big moment
and you know that was a play that i
think i've told you this before the
cardinals stole from the tennessee
titans team that i was on during that
year we had a big play against the
steelers in the regular season to win
home field advantage uh that that was
that play and they stole that and of
course it worked out great for them for
the touchdown but man that was a that's
a great one i i should have picked my
earl campbell you know deck in the
defender in the chest and this jersey
tearing away i should have done that to
my old texas alum friend uh what else
did you have on your list well no but
think about it with earl campbell it was
two moments like that
in the same play from the helmet to the
stomach of isaiah robertson and clearly
a legal move now in the nfl to the
tearaway jersey something they did away
with because they were tearing jerseys
all the time but not in that kind of
spectacular fashion that that to me we
both blew it we both lost the draft by
not putting that one in there
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports